[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con la
organización mundial de la salud
manifestó su preocupación ante el
aumento de los contagios de kobe 19 que
se registra en europa desde hace algunas
semanas esto sumado al bajo índice de
vacunación en grupos prioritarios en
algunos países despierta las alarmas
para analizar este tema nos acompaña
nuestro asesor científico el doctor
oscar franco epidemiólogo director del
instituto de medicina social y
preventiva de la universidad de berna
académico de harvard y de la universidad
erasmo de rotterdam doctor como puede
explicarse este aumento de casos en
europa en este momento que tanto incide
la presencia de la variante delta
si estamos viendo un aumento de casos en
europa específicamente hay tres países
en europa que están en el top tres de
los mayor número de casos diarios en la
última semana está de georgia esta
posada está montenegro pero también se
ha visto aumento de casos en rusia en
francia en españa es una combinación de
factores vemos con una repetición del
año pasado por un lado ahora tenemos
nuevas variantes que son más
transmisibles tenemos también una
relajación no solamente de las medidas
sino de la población también y tenemos
una desacelerada de esa levedad
aceleración de la vacunación en un 14%
tener último mes por dos factores uno es
por acceso y el otro es porque todavía
hay grandes proporciones de la población
que son renuentes o que son escépticas
acerca de las vacunas entonces estamos
viendo esa variante nueva la variante
delta que es más transmisible y la
combinación de factores que hacen que
tomemos con preocupación la situación en
europa
pasado el verano y la temporada alta de
turismo usted cree que los gobiernos
volverán a endurecer las restricciones
estamos viendo señales de eso vimos cómo
se hacían hace poco el anuncio de las
restricciones para los viajeros de los
eeuu que podrían entrar a la unión
europea yo creo que gradualmente van a
seguir aumentando las restricciones y
los casos siguen aumentando esperemos
que no pero lo que estamos viendo es
como una repetición del año pasado mucha
relajación mucha espera que las cosas
van a seguir bien mucho optimismo pero
que es importante no bajar la guardia y
lo que estamos viendo es que están
bajando la guardia estamos bajando la
guardia en europa
además algunos países europeos exigen un
pase sanitario y muchísimos ciudadanos
lo rechazan por considerarlo entre otras
cosas un ataque a sus libertades
individuales usted considera que esta es
una medida efectiva para contrarrestar
esa tendencia al alza en los contagios
si hay que admitir que esos pasaportes
de vacunación se pueden tener pues una
intromisión en las libertades
individuales de las personas sin embargo
tienen un aspecto muy positivo porque
ayudar a las comunidades a integrarse a
golpeada a esa tan anhelada anormalidad
que teníamos antes no es la primera vez
que tenemos pasaportes de inmunización
ya lo habíamos tenido hace cien años en
1920 para la viruela en la lucha contra
la viruela y ayudaron muchísimo para
poder erradicar esa enfermedad que tanto
afectaba a la población mundial entonces
yo creo que estos pasaportes si pueden
ayudar
y teniendo en cuenta que gran parte de
la población escolar no está vacunada
como cree usted que deberán proceder las
autoridades ahora que faltan pocos días
para que los niños y los jóvenes
regresen presencialmente a las aulas
y una de las cosas que hemos aprendido
que es muy importante durante la
pandemia es que es fundamental mantener
los colegios y las escuelas abiertas no
solamente porque son espacios de
educación sino también de alimentos de
alojamiento de cuidado para muchos de
los niños que no tienen un lugar de
protección entonces es fundamental
mantenerlos abiertos pero mantenerlos
abiertos de una manera segura
asegurándonos que los profesores que los
docentes tienen acceso a las vacunas
programas completos de vacunación y que
los niños que tienen ciertos compromisos
en el sistema inmunitario puedan también
tener acceso a las vacunas los niños
mayores de 12 años por ahora entonces es
fundamental mantener los colegios
abiertos
doctor muchísimas gracias como siempre
por su análisis y ahí el llamado
continúa haciendo tanto en europa como
en américa latina' a vacunarse muchas
gracias a nuestros televidentes también
continúen en france 24 ya volvemos con
más
[Música]